la ministre j'ordonne au ministre de la
défense
et aux chefs d'états majors de mettre
les forces de dissuasion de l'armée
russe en régime spécial d'alerté au
combat je
marque je voulais vous faire réagir un
petit peu assez secours secours petits
sont de 2,2 vadimir poutine est ce que
c'est une réelle menace russe vous
l'avez rapidement évoquée puisque c'est
plutôt d'une certaine manière voilà une
volonté d'impressionner de prendre la
main peut-être avant ces pourparlers qui
pourrait qui pourrait avoir lieu à toute
façon il ne fait que répéter ce qu'il
avait semblé annoncé dans ce discours
juste avant l'intervention où il a
menacé ce qui se mettra en travers sa
route de conséquences pires que celles
qu'il pourrait imaginer dans leurs pires
cauchemars donc évidemment tu on avait
déjà compris de quoi il parlait c'est
une réaction dit il dans ce même
discours prononcé aujourd'hui aux
décisions des leaders de l'otan parce
que oui la pression diplomatique
est en train d'escalader on voit que
beaucoup de pays fermé leur espace
aérien il ya ces sanctions financières
chaque jour de plus en plus durs qui
vise dorénavant le coeur du système
économique russe avait compris la banque
centrale
donc c'est vrai qu'il y à il ya cette
pression qui est en train de s'accentuer
comme on l'a évoqué sur le terrain ça ne
se passe peut-être pas comme il l'avait
imaginé donc il y as peut-être une
volonté de vladimir poutine d'utiliser
évidemment cette menace ce chantage
diront certains nucléaire je rappelle
juste pour ceux qui ont oublié la guerre
froide que la russie la première
puissance nucléaire au monde plus de
6300 têtes nucléaires entre 5800 aux
états unis les autres pays à commencer
par la chine sont très très loin
derrière la france en compte 300 mais la
simple évocation de cette menace
évidemment les etats unis l'otan ont
réagi en affirmant que c'est
inacceptable
mais c'était évidemment l'argument le
plus fort si j'ose dire dont dispose la
dîmière poutine et il est prêt à en
utiliser peut-être pour obtenir des
gains diplomatique aussi parce qu'il
sait que les sanctions vont frapper sans
doute beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup
plus vite qu'on ne le pense et parce
qu'elles sont assez drastiques restez
avec nous marque paie mal avec nous
également en plateau notre invité
bonjour madame leroy y est un genre vous
êtes réalisatrice ancienne
correspondante en russie notamment vous
est également l'auteur de 1996 hold up
avec vous je voulais avec vous au réagir
un petit peu à ce que disait marc
perelman y en actions à un instant sur
les sanctions qui ont qui ont adopté à
l'égard à l'égard de la russie par de
nombreux pays occidentaux on pense
notamment aux dernières 1 qui vise les
banques russes qu'elle va être à votre
avis l'impact sur le quotidien des
russes vous le vous le connaissez bien
vous avez été correspondante en russie
l'impact sur le quotidien des russes il
est déjà palpable
les distributeurs automatiques
fonctionne encore mais on observe des
files d'attentes je parlais hier avec
une amie journaliste qui rentrait de la
région de belgorod et qui me disait ben
voila je suis rentré à moscou je suis à
la maison j'ai dix mille roubles
peut-être 120 ou 130 euros en liquide à
la maison et je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer demain elle décrivait une
sensation d'enfermement donc cessons ces
sanctions ont bien évidemment pour
objectif de
déstabiliser
de d'ennuyer
l'establishment et l'oligarchie elles
ont aussi des conséquences sur la sur la
vie quotidienne des russes qui par
ailleurs ne sont pas informés de la
réalité de ce que vous nommez l'invasion
de ce qui est une guerre et qui est
décrit en russie toujours comme une
opération spéciale dans un but de
dénazification de l'ukraine
effectivement il en est on a vu
également quelque chose peut-être
d'assez nouveau ces mobilisations de
certains russes on a vu ces dernières
heures dans plusieurs villes de russie
des manifestations anti-guerre d'une
partie de
2,2 le la population russe est ce que
l'opinion publique on imagine que non
mais ce que l'opinion publique peut
avoir un poids vis-à-vis de cette guerre
selon vous
l'opinion publique ça c'est une
formulation assez monolithique qui ne
correspond pas à la réalité ceci dit oui
ces mouvements existe il n'existe pas
uniquement dans les villes de l'ouest de
la russie aujourd'hui y avait des gens
dans la rue à novossibirsk par exemple
la difficulté c'est l'accès à des
sources d'information
autonome
indépendante qui se raréfient et la
russie verrouille de plus en plus
puisque les médias qu'ils ne veulent pas
se plier aux injonctions d'utiliser le
vocabulaire du kremlin et bien sont
menacés de ne pas pouvoir émettre et le
procureur général russe aujourd'hui a
annoncé que tout citoyen qui se rendrait
coupable
de trahison de partage d'informations au
sujet de la situation en ukraine et bien
été exposé a effectivement à des
poursuites pour haute trahison donc 20
ans de prison donc là le l'encerclement
est très fort et je crois qu'il faut
vraiment loué le courage de ces russes
mais aussi les biélorusses qui
manifestent contre ce que appelle la
guerre de poutine